[Music]
welcome to the president's design award
2020 award ceremony
the newest crop of recipients with
outstanding words have created a better
singapore and a better world by design
the first pda 2020 designer of the year
as an educator i believe in the value of
education education has molded me to be
who i am today
the dedication to serve a larger
community within make them truly
deserving of the world
[Music]
we see our projects providing more than
homes water food clean air and sunshine
but also peace love and trust
it's been a very rewarding journey
when we see how the seniors enjoy the
space
comfort ability can be adapted across
the world that other countries can learn
and emulate
we dreamt of a place where the children
feel safe
they can feel a gentle breeze in a hot
afternoon or even play in the tropical
area
children need to dream
and i think it's the environment that
allows them to actually cherish those
things
with resource efficient architectures
joining forces in pushing the boundaries
of technology and design
for not just your faith and trust in us
we have equally invested in labor along
us
is indeed pronounced
keep your eyes open and your mind sharp
jewel is a place where the world meets
singapore and singapore meets the world
an icon that everyone in singapore can
be very proud of
[Music]
you don't need to be a hero to reduce
your waste to zero let's leave life not
so convenient and reduce
[Music]
you